Asian in the Ugandan capital Kampala is
a challenge to all people
but it's even worse for people with
disabilities like Fred Vitale
he was left unable to walk after
contracting polio I was born in a poor
family so at the age of five I became
disabled so I couldn't get money to get
a tricycle or wheelchair so I had to
crawl - every day going to school
Fred struggled through finished school
and got a scholarship and study design
at McCreery University
he's now employed by an artist agency
after work he moves around the streets
of Kampala to inspire other disabled
people through his disability art
project his motto
don't be defeated despite the disability
I thought because I had acquired some
knowledge in the heart and design I
thought I could use this as a tool to
empower my disability get the skills
which they can use to sustain themselves
every weekend he uses the agency
premises to meet people with different
disabilities they create unique products
like jewelry watches and handicrafts and
then they sell them
Martha is deaf others are physically
disabled and one is blind but their
project is not all about money
they also socialize freely something
that itself is not common in Uganda
project manager Fred Vitali says it has
not been easy running the disability art
project they have to find their
materials on the streets and in garbage
dumps this clock is made mostly from
plastic waste we are trying to come up
with this product to be our signature
product it is the unique it's about
recycling which is very good we have a
challenge in Kampala disposal can these
bottle tops everywhere so we are trying
to make them into use its artwork that
protects the environment this project is
something I feel in myself that it's my
work
it's something I feel I should have good
and that I read of Ivan Ivan rima bogo
so far they have one private sponsor but
Kampala City Council is currently
considering whether to fund them then
perhaps the project will get its own
center